madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les membres du gouvernement
mesdames et messieurs les députés mes
chers collègues
horreur
sidération
angoisse le monde est aujourd'hui en
état de choc devant la violence de
l'attaque terroriste qui a frappé
Israël bienvenue dans les grands débats
ce mardi 10 octobre l'actualité
internationale percute l'ordre du jour
de l'Assemblée nationale yelbron Pivet
rend hommage au victimes des attaques
terroristes perpétré par le Hamas contre
Israël puis les présidents de chacun des
groupes politiques représentés dans
l'hémicycle adresse une question à la
première ministre Elisabeth born qui
répond à l'ensemble de la représent
nationale une séance de question au
gouvernement très
particulière devant cette barbarie je
veux redire ici qu'Israël est un pays
ami à qui je veux réaffirmer au nom de
la représentation
nationale notre totale solidarité et
notre soutien
inconditionnel en hommage aux victimes
en signe de solidarité avec avec leurs
familles comme avec celles qui sont sans
nouvell de personnes prises en otage ou
porté disparu je vous demande mesdames
et messieurs les membres du gouvernement
mesdames et messieurs les députés de
bien vouloir observer une minute de
silence
donc l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au Gouvernement je vous
rappelle que la Conférence des
Présidents a décidé que les 10 premières
questions seraient consacré à la
situation en Israël à raison d'une
question par groupe et qu'elle donnerait
lieu à une réponse globale de madame la
Première ministre la première question
va être posée par Monsieur le Kester
soti pour le groupe les
[Applaudissements]
républicains merci madame la
Présidente madame la Première ministre
je voudrais m'associer toute à la fois à
vos mots et à ceux de madame la
Présidente oui c'est avec sidération et
horreur que nous avons reçu samedi matin
ces image
terrifiante horrible venant
d'Israël des massacres de civils étaient
perpétrés des vieillards ont été traqués
jusque dans leur
domicile des enfants ont été kidnappé
des femmes ont été violées
aujourd'hui les terroristes du Hamas qui
ont commis ces exactions
terrifiantes menace d'assassiner les
otages dans d'autres temps dans d'autres
lieux nous avons connu les mêmes
scénarios à l'image de ce 13 novembre
2015 sur les terrasses parisiennes ù des
jeunes comme dans le désert d' néev ont
été pris pour
à l'image du 14 juillet 2016 à Nice
alors notre réaction elle doit être
celle de tous les républicains de tous
ceux qui sont attachés à la liberté
c'est-à-dire condamnés sans réserve ceux
qui ont commis ses exaction c'est
terroristes elle doit être aussi de
soutenir
totalement Israël en lui exprimant notre
fraternité en humanité madame la
Première ministre nos pensées se tour à
he Proche Orient où les peuples
Israéliens et Palestiniens souffrent
encore une fois je souhaite depuis cette
assemblée exprimer une pensée emplie
d'humanité pour les otages les civils
tués en Israël par les actes de terreur
perpétrés par le Hamas ainsi que pour
les civils qui à Gaza sont tués sous les
bombes de tsal nous condamnons tous ces
crimes de
guerre un seul message doit parvenir du
concert des nations en cette heure si
grave une heure qui n rien propice aux
polémiques franco-français un seul
message doit parvenir du concert des
nations cessz le feu c'est un message
qui nous vient du Secrétaire général des
Nations unies du pape ou de Loula qui
préside le Conseil de sécurité des
Nations unies cessz le feu madame la
Première ministre il s'appelaient Tamar
et Jonathan ils étaient parents de trois
enfants et ont été tués dans leur foyer
il s'appellent chiri Ariel dit no ce
sont des mères de famille des enfants
des personnes âgées des adolescents
enlevés et pris en otage actuellement
dans la bande de Gaza tous sont des
victimes du terrorisme du Hamas qui
depuis samedi sè la mort et la
désolation en Israël déjà 900 civiles
tués dont qu de nos compatriotes et plus
de 2600 blessés des victimes assassinées
mtilé parce
qu'israélienne
près de 150 otages qui vivent en ce
moment même l'insoutenable attendent que
leurs jolers les marchandent madame la
Première ministre comment le
gouvernement compte-il assurer la
sécurité de nos concitoyens sur place
mais également sur notre propre
territoire je vous remercie merci
beaucoup monsieur le
Président la parole est à madame la
Présidente Le Pen pour le rassemblement
national
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre chers collègues ce 7 octobre
2023 nous avons assisté à ce que nous
pensions ne plus jamais revoir dans
l'histoire de l'humanité des pogrommes
des pogromes sur la terre même d'Israël
au cours desqueles on a tué des femmes
des enfants des hommes uniquement parce
qu'ils étaient juifs ces attaques sont
un crime contre les humains mais aussi
un crime contre la paix contre cet
extraordinaire é l processus qui ces
derniers mois semblait progresser
rapprochant Israël et les nations
arabes nous Français nous avons revécu
avec effroid les horreurs du Bataclan ou
les tuerie d'enfants de Mohamed Mera les
scènes d'une violence inouie contre des
civils ou des militaires blessés ou tués
les prises d'ottage y compris de
personnes âgées et d'enfants sont d'une
inhumanité rare
je réaffirme ici solennellement notre
soutien au peuple israélien frappé au
cœur aux familles touché dans leur chair
et à tous ceux qui souffrre dans leur
âme de ces abominations la lutte contre
l'adre islamiste que ce soit en Israël
ou en France est un der majeur pour
notre époque notamment car elle doit
libérer certaines populations dont je
crois une partie du peuple palestinien
prise en otage par des mouvements
islamiste terroristes cette lutte
demande des moyens mais elle demande
surtout une volonté politique pour nous
responsable politique français l'urgence
est aujourd'hui de protéger physiquement
mais aussi moralement les Français juifs
si sur le plan physique le gouvernement
a annoncé le déploiement de forces de
l'ordre sur le plan moral comment
comptez-vous faire respecter en France
l'interdiction de l'apologie du
terrorisme première étape dans la lutte
contre
l'islamisme le massacre de jeunes a une
rêve partie l'exécution de bébés de
vieillards d'innocents le kidna age
compris d'enfant n'est pas un acte de
résistance c'est un crime
terroriste les actes du
Hamas doivent être condamné comme leur
projet politique qui n'est pas la paix
et qui exclut toute coexistence avec
l'État d'Israël notre condamnation est
totale le terrorisme n'est pas
d'expression aucune cause ne le justifie
aucun contexte ne l'excuse la fin ne
justifie jamais les
moyens j'exprime ici au nom des
socialistes notre solidarité avec les
familles des victimes et le peuple
israélien traumatisé notre soutien à
Israël comme à toute démocratie frappée
par le terrorisme est indéfectible dans
les limit du droit
international le droit humanitaire doit
être respecté le siège de Gaza n'est pas
acceptable la déshumanisation des
Palestiniens par le ministre israélien
de la Défense est une insulte à notre
commune humanité infliger une punition
collective à des populations civiles est
insupportable chaque vie
compte notre conviction est inchangée
il n'y aura pas de paix durable sans
État palestinien et sans garantie de
sécurité pour Israël nous appelons dans
l'immédiia le gouvernement français et
l'Union européenne à prendre une
initiative diplomatique pour inesser le
feu avant de convoquer ultérieurement un
sommet pour une issue politique la
guerre à ces trop nombreux partisans la
paix a maintenant besoin de ses
combattant
merci je vous
remercie madame la
Présidente ministre le 7 octobre 2023
restera dans l'histoire comme un jour où
le genre humain a montré sa face la plus
sombre le Hamas a mis en œuvre une
attaque organisée coordonnée visant à
prendre le maximum de civil israélien en
otage quand ils n'étaient pas
sommairement exécutés chez eux parfois
par famille
entière ce ne sont pas des crimes de
guerre une qualification qui s'applique
uniquement lorsqu'ils sont commis par
une armée régulière ici les méthodes
employées ont changé de nature et de
degré
elles sont en effet désormais
comparables à ce que l'État islamique a
pu faire de
pire le groupe horizon et apparenté
condamne fermement et unanimement ces
actes terroristes perpétrés par une
organisation terroriste il n'y a pas de
place pour aucune ambigué qui
bénéficierait à ceux qui commettent des
opérations barbares sur des femmes et
des enfants nous sommes solidairire du
peuple israélien et de toutes les
victimes je veux avoir une pensée
particulière pour les familles des
quatre Français dont la mort a été
confirmée à cette heure par le qu d'orsé
et celles qui sont encore dans une
longue et douloureuse attente la vérité
c'est que la cause palestinienne mérite
mieux qu'une organisation islamiste
terroriste qui n'hésite pas à prendre
des populations civiles qu'ell soit
israéliennees palestinen comme boucliers
humains et plus personne n'ignore que le
but ultime du Hamas n'est pas la paix
mais bien la destruction pure et simple
de l'État
d'Israël madame la Première ministre
pouvez-vous indiquer à la représentation
nationale quelle mesure la France compte
prendre pour assurer le rapatriement de
nos ressortissant lorsqu'il le demande
comment prévenir ensuite l'importation
de ce conflit dans notre pays plus
généralement enfin quelle est la
position de la France sur l'évolution de
la situation au Moyen-Orient et en
Méditerranée je vous remercie merci
beaucoup la parole est à madame la
Présidente Chatelin pour le groupe
écologiste madame la présidente madame
la Première ministre chers collègues les
écologistes pensent aux familles aux
victimes à toutes celles et ceux qui
sont dans l'angoisse et dans l'attente
de nouvelles de leurs proches notre
solidarité est totale les Israéliens ont
le droit absolu de pouvoir vivre en
sécurité les écologist condamne sans
réserve les atrocités commises par les
terroristes du Hamas aucune lutte ne
justifie les tirs de roquettes contre un
hôpital aucune cause ne justifie la
prise d'otage et l'assassinat de civils
aucun acte de résistance ne justifie le
massacre de 260 festivaliers les
écologistes ne seront jamais au côté de
seul de celles et ceux qui sèment la
terreur et la mort nous serons toujours
au côté de celles et ceux qui uvrent
pour la
paix face à la barbarie seul le droit
international est notre
réponse aujourd'hui les bombardements
incessant de Gaza et la mise en place
d'un siège total privant 2,3 millions de
Gazaoui d'eau de nourriture et
d'électricité nous alarme au plus haut
point les propos déshumanisants du
ministre israélien de la Défense
comparant les Gazaoui à des animaux
laisse crainreun massacre dans la prison
à C l'ouvert que Gaza nous ne pouvons
plus tolérer cela la communauté
internationale a fait le Paris que le
conflit israëlo-palestinien sétiendrait
de lui-même il a fait le choix de
regarder ailleurs les 72 dernières
heures nous rappellent à quel point
c'est une question géopolitique centrale
et la France a une responsabilité
majeure en tant que membre permanent du
Conseil de sécurité des Nations unies le
gouvernement français ne peut se
contenter d'apporter un soutien aveugle
au gouvernement israélien la France doit
réaffirmer sa position historique pour
la coexistence de deux états vivant en
paix et en sécurité les Palestiniens ont
le droit absolu de vivre libre dans un
état souverain l'urgence est donc cesser
le feu au respect du droit international
et à la protection des civils madame la
Première ministre comment votre
gouvernement compte-il agir en faveur de
la déescalade comment la France
compte-elle au sein d'une démarche
européenne résolument pour la paix et la
protection des civiles quelle que soit
la cause que l'on défend elle restera
toujours déshonorée par le massacre
aveugle d'une foule innocente où le
tueur c'est d'avance qu'il atteindra la
femme et l'enfant disait Albert Camu
depuis samedi dernier les populations
civiles israéliennes sont victimes d'une
attaque terroriste massive et sans
précédent de la part du Hamas qui a
causé l'effroid dans la population
israélienne plus de 700 personnes ont
été assassinées dont plus de 200
50 personnes qui participai à un moment
de fête plus de 150 israéliens hommes
femmes et enfants sont retenus en otage
par les terroristes du Hamas dans la
bande de Gaza des quartiers et des
villages ont été réduit en cendre et les
roquettes continuent de pleuvoir sur les
villes israéliennes mettant en danger
plus de 9 millions de civils cette
violence nous indigne et nous boueverse
profondément et ne peut laisser la place
à aucune ambigué d'interprétation quant
aux motivations de ce groupe terroriste
face à ces crimes nous ne pouvons rester
silencieux ou pire indulgent je veux le
dire simplement aucune lutte ne justifie
le terrorisme aucun conflit territorial
n'explique ses horreurs car au-delà des
communautés c'est bien la dignité et
l'humanité qui sont aujourd'hui
attaqué nous condamnons fermement ces
attentats les manifestations nombreuses
qui ont eu lieu hier en fin de journée
ont marqué la solidarité du peuple de
France vis-à-vis du peuple israélien si
durement touché nous étions nombreux à y
être et j'avoue avoir été
particulièrement touché par la
fraternité qui s'y'est exprimée je veux
dire au nom du groupe de mon groupe tout
notre soutien au peuple israélien nous
adressons nos condances aux proches des
victimes de ces attentats et sommes au
côté des familles des otages madame la
Première ministre pouvez-vousnous
pouvez-vous nous dire quelles seront les
actions à venir de la France et de
l'Europe surtout dans ce contexte de
crise aigue je vous remercie merci
beaucoup monsieur le
Président les députés du groupe lot
comme le monde entier ont découvert eux
aussi avec effroi les attaques du
mouvement terroriste hamass contre la
population civil israélienne c'est avec
la plus grande fermeté que nous les
condamnons sans aucune réserve queles
que soi les causes les humains ne
peuvent pas en arriver à de tels niveau
d'atrocité sur leur semblabl les
assassinats les prises d'otage d'enfants
adultes de femmes ou de personnes âgées
sont des actes monstrueux nous apportons
notre totale solidarité aux familles aux
proches des victimes des disparus des
otages du Hamas prises dans un chantage
odieux il s'agit pour la représentation
française et pour les responsables
politiques que nous sommes de faire
preuve de responsabilité et de dignité
dans notre expression loin de toute
querelle politicienne les prises de
position avec de la surenchè sans aucune
nuance celles cherchant des excuses ou
appelant à la vengeance ne peuvent
décemment être acceptables ou prises
avec un conflit d'une telle complexité
il appartient au-delà de l'émotion
légitime immédiate que la France l'Union
européenne et l'ONU puissent commencer à
envisager des solutions pour éviter un
engrenage incontrôlable madame la
Première ministre c'est dans ce sens
qu'il nous faut tous
œuvrer je vous
remercie
la parole est à monsieur le Président
chassigne pour le groupe
GDR madame la Première ministre le
groupe GDR et les députés communistes
ont condamné sans réserve l'attaque
terroriste perpétrée par le Hamas sur
les civils
israéliens nous avons nous avons nous
avons
exprimé tous ici notre plus profonde
émotion face à la violence aveugle qui
s'est déchaîné sur des femmes des
enfants des vieillards une condamnation
qui s'impose mais elle ne suffira pas à
mettre fin aux violences à protéger les
populations à trouver le chemin de la
paix et de la sécurité aujourd'hui Gaza
est sous le feu des bombes privé d'eau
et
d'électricité le gouvernement israélien
israélien d'extrême droite promet de
traiter ses habitants comme des animaux
une vengeance terrifiante qui s'abat là
aussi sur des femmes des enfants des
vieillards des millions de civils
innocents la France doit aussi madame la
Première ministre condamner cette
opération venguresse qui va plonger plus
encore les peuples les Israéliens et
Palestiniens dans le désespoir et le
deuil la France doit lancer une
initiative diplomatique forte pour
imposer le respect du droit et mettre
fin à 75 ans de duplicité de la
communauté internationale sur la
question
palestinienne une communauté
internationale qui par la voix de l'ONU
condamne la politique colonialiste
israélienne et le traitement réservés
aux Palestiniens privés de leurs droits
fondamentaux une communauté
internationale qui ferme les yeux sur
les résolutions bafoué par Israël la
France doit reprendre le flambeau de la
paix qu'elle a abandonné depuis tant
d'années être à l'initiative d'un
Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU qui mette
fin à la politique d'occupation et se
consacre à la recherche d'une solution à
deux états
coexistant un état pour le peuple
israélien et untat pour le peuple
palestinien ATS dont les frontières
serai protégé par la communauté
internationale alors alors seulement
seulement nous gagnerons une paix
durable pour mettre fin à la spirale
destructrice mesdames et messieurs les
députés ne nous trompons pas sur ce qui
vient de se passer nous faisons face à
un changement
d'échelle l'ampleur de l'opération sa
complexité son exécution tous ces le
démontre la barbarie et le niveau de
violence inimaginable nous rappelle les
pires moments de notre combat contre
l'État
islamique ceux qui ont soutenu financé
et armé le Hamas ont basculé avec lui
dans
l'ignominie dans ces heures graves la
responsabilité doit guider notre
action notre message est clair
le président de la République l'a
rappelé ce matin d'abord un soutien
total à Israël et à sa population nous
nous tenons à leur côté et Israël a le
droit de se défendre face au
terrorisme face à la barbarie des
attaques
terroristesne ce droit
ensuite nous devons tout mettre en œuvre
pour permettre la désescalade et éviter
l'embrasement de la région tous les
civils doivent être protégés et le droit
international
[Applaudissements]
respecté mardi 17 octobre la séance
publique s'ouvre par une nouvelle minute
de silence cette fois à la mémoire de
Dominique Bernard professeur de lettrre
assassiné quelques jours plus tôt à
haras par un étranger fich s l'ambiance
est grave
recueilli mesdames et messieurs les
députés mes chers
collègues la
France est en
deuil 3 ans après Samuel
pati un autre professeur un homme de
culture et de dialogue qui avait la
passion de transmettre la connaissance
Dominique Bernard et tombé sous les
coups d'un terroriste qu'il tentait
courageusement de
raisonner plus encore qu'un crime c'est
une profamation qui s'est commise à
haras car en France l'école est sacrée
elle est le sanctuaire du savoir où se
forme la
nation s'attaquer à l'école à travers un
professeur revient à défier notre é
publublique tout entière notre modèle
humaniste de société que nous défendrons
toujours hier dans toutes les écoles de
France les élèves et leurs enseignants
ont observé une minute de
silence je ne doute pas que chacun
d'entre vous mesdames et messieurs les
députés se soit associé à ce moment de
recueillement de civisme et d'unité mais
il me paraît important indispensable
même que la représent nationale à son
tour rendre hommage à Dominique Bernard
et Samuel
Patti je souhaite également que nous
exprimions notre solidarité à nos amis
belges et suédois durement frappés hier
à leur tour par le terrorisme
islamiste pour nos deux
professeurs pour toutes les victimes du
terrorisme en Europe et ailleurs je vous
demande mesdames et messieurs les
membres du gouvernement mesdames
messieurs les députés de bien vouloir
observer une minute de
silence quelques minutes plus tard ce
même 17 octobre changement de ton dans
l'hémicycle Mathilde Panau est la
première à prendre la parole la
présidente du groupe la France insoumise
à l'Assemblée nationale interpelle la
première ministre avec une question au
vitriol réponse ferme d'Élisabeth borne
l'échange marque la
séance Dominique Bernard a été assassiné
et ses collègues de travail blessés
parce qu'ils ont affronté eux-mêmes la
mort plutôt que de laisser les élèves en
danger Aurélie sa collègue décrit son
rapport aux jeunes auquel il enseignait
les lettres tu étais là pour eux il
l'avait compris et se nourrissait en
désordre de ta passion contagieuse pour
la littérature de ta foi en l'homme
desespoirs que tu mettais en eux voici
ce que font les enseignants tous les
jours notre pensée émue va à l'ensemble
de celles et ceux qui partageant la même
profession sont d'autant plus accablés
depuis
vendredi l'école a été visée vous devez
prendre madame la Première ministre
toutes les mesures pour protéger les
personnels et les élèves mais surtout
l'école doit continuer à œuvrer à
l'émancipation de tous les citoyens pour
cela elle doit être dotée de tous les
moyens nécessaires allez-vous comme le
demandent les enseignants recruter tous
les personnels essentiels à
l'encadrement merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente merci beaucoup la parole est
à madame la Première
ministre depuis le 7
octobre les voix de la France insoumises
manquent à la condamnation unanime de la
barbarie terroriste elle manque à
l'unité nationale vous avez tenté de
justifier vos ambiguités mais ce matin
la réalité est apparue au grand jour la
justice est saisie elle tranchera
mais en entendant ces propos je pense à
ces jeunes tués lors d'une fête je pense
à ces massacres dans les kibuts de Berry
et de karasa je pense à ces femmes ces
hommes ces personnes ces personnes âgées
et ces enfants enlevés pour vous ce ne
sont pas des actes terroristes pour moi
vous vous excluez du champ
républicain sur tous les bancs de
l'Assemblée nationale majoritaire ou
d'opposition on s'interroge pas moi de
12 questions ce jour-là sur l'attentat
d'aras alors que la France a été placée
en situation d'urgence
attentat vendredi dernier Dominique
Bernard est mort
dansenseigné assassiné par la barbarie
du terrorisme
islamiste face à ces tragédies et à leur
répétitions les mots peuvent désormais
nous sembler usés et
inutiles pourtant je me refuse d'y
renoncer et je veux donc dire ici et
avec vous aux familles des victimes à
tous les enseignants de France et à tous
les agents de l'éducation nationale je
veux leur dire tout notre soutien et
toute notre
affection je le dis les islamistes
veulent tenir éloignés du savoir le plus
grand nombre pour imposer leur
obscurantisme notre école à la française
elle défend la démocratisation du savoir
pour
tous les islamistes ils veulent
soumettre les femmes notre école
accueille toutes les petites filles de
France avec tous les petits garçons de
France pour leur transmettre le
savoir les islamistes veulent imposer le
règne de la religion à l'école nous
imposons celui de la République et de la
laïcité dans toutes les écoles de France
3 ans après l'assassinat barbare de
Samuel pati encore une fois la
République est attaquée
meurtrie encore une fois l'école de la
République ceux qui la font vivre sont
pris pour cible et c'est toute la nation
qui est endeuillée si l'école publique
laïque est ciblée c'est bien parce
qu'elle est le meilleur rempart contre
l'obscurantisme c'est parce qu'elle
développe l'esprit critique face au
dogmatisme alors ce nouveau crime nous
oblige une nouvelle fois nous unir et
d'une seule voix à condamn le terrorisme
et la barbarie qui frappe nos écoles
rien ne peut les justifier ni ici ni
ailleurs nos 12 millions d'élèves en
France ont une chance inouie pouvoir
compter sur 860000 enseignants à leur
côté 860000 enseignants et toute la
communauté éducative autour d'eux qui
ont une vocation démocratiser le savoir
leur permettre à chacun de s'élever de
briser les destins écrit par avance
c'est ça la vocation des enseignants
cette vocation il la pousse chaque jour
à son maximum et je le dis à haras leur
réaction a été absolument exemplaire
pour mettre à l'abri et protéger leurs
élèves la République a été frpp au cœur
à aras dans cette hémicycle où nous
incarnons la nation je tiens à rendre un
hommage solennel à Dominique Bernard qui
par son sacrifice a sauvé de nombreuses
vies un homme rare un professeur
exceptionnel je pense également à David
à Jacques gravement blessé à Christian
et au proviseur qui ont fait preuve
d'une bravoure hors norme je tiens à
saluer l'ensemble des personnels du
collège du lycée Gambetta qui ont
protégé leurs élèves nos enfants
je tiens aussi à exprimer notre
gratitude au servicees de sécurité de
secours nos policiers étaient sur les
lieux en seulement 4 minutes mettant fin
au carnage nos soignants ont pris en
charge David et Jacques et Contin
continu d'accompagner psychologiquement
les élèves et la communauté éducative
merci à eux 3 ans après Samuel pati le
terrorisme islamiste tente à nouveau de
nous diviser en s'attaquant à notre
école passeuse de nos valeurs
républicaines face à ce cancer qui
menace notre cohésion notre réponse doit
être ferme unie déterminée au-delà de
nos émotions profondes de notre colère
légitime et de notre aspiration à la
justice il est de notre responsabilité
de poser les questions essentielles pour
l'avenir de notre pays madame la
Première ministre quel engagement
prenez-vous pour protéger notre jeunesse
et nos enseignants face à
l'obscurantisme comment mieux armer
notre public face à cet ennemi assidieux
notre devoir est d'agir avec déter tion
et clairyance nous devons à nos
concitoyens aux victimes et à leurs
famille non pas seulement des paroles
mais des actes forts et concrets pour
garantir la péritnité de notre modèle
républicain madame la députée 3 ans
pratiquement jour pour jour après
l'assassinat sauvage de Samuel paatti
c'est à nouveau une école qui est prise
pour cible cela n'a rien d'anodin
l'école c'est la transmission des
savoirs c'est l'apprentissage de la
liberté c'est le creuser de la
citoyenneté et de la laïcité l'école
c'est
l'émancipation c'est notre jeunesse qui
se forme qui grandit qui choisit sa vie
s'en prendre aux enseignants c'est s'en
prendre à notre modèle républicain alors
je le dis fermement nous serons là pour
protéger les Français nous serons là
pour protéger la République nous
resterons Unis rassemblés autour de nos
valeurs l'obscurantisme et la terreur ne
l'emporteront
jamais l de cette cette séance de
question d'actualité la gauche
interpelle aussi le gouvernement sur
l'offensive terrestre israélienne qui
s'annonce imminente à Gaza alors que
l'ONU averti d'une catastrophe
humanitaire à
venir la parole est à Monsieur David
guirud pour le groupe la France
insoumise merci madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre nous n'avons
plus que quelques heures pour éviter le
pire en Palestine ce samedi 14 octobre
la rapporteur spéciale de l'ONU dans les
territoires palestiniens occupés a
déclaré je la cite que les Palestiniens
de Gaza court le risque d'un nettoyage
ethnique massif un nettoyage ethnique à
l'heure où nous parlons un million de
personnes de Palestiniens sont sous la
coupe d'un ordre d'évacuation que l'ONG
Médecin du Monde qualifie d'impensable
d'infaisable et d'irréaliste le
président israélien a averti le monde
samedi dernier en déclarant à propos des
Palestiniens je le cite que c'est toute
une nation qui est responsable il
annonce donc une punition collective
contre les Palestiniens pourtant
interdite par le droit international ce
même droit international qu'Israël a
déjà baoué plus de 100 fois depuis 1947
nous n'avons plus que quelques heures
les milliers de bombes sur 2 millions de
civils la privation d'eau de nourriture
le déplacement forcés nous dirige vers
une catastrophe humanitaire mais aussi
une catastrophe diplomatique nous devons
exiger un cesser le feu pour nos
compatriotes franco-israéliens au tâes
du Hamas nous devons exiger un cesser le
feu pour nos compatriotes
franco-palestiniens bloqués à Gaza
tellement absent vos discours d'ailleurs
comment comptez-vous les protéger nous
devons tout faire pour que le feu
s'arrête la peine et la erreur que nous
avons éprouvé face au crime de guerre du
Hamas ne peut pas nous conduire un
soutien inconditionnel sur ce que fait
l'état israélien à Gaza la France est
trop silencieuse sur ce grave risque de
nettoyage
ethnique je vous rappelle qu'Israël a
été frappé par une offensive terroriste
sans précédent dans son
histoire je vous rappelle qu'elle est
ama organisation terroriste est entré en
Israël pour tuer des Juifs des hommes
des femmes des enfants des bébés les
amain organisation terroristes et des
décès acolyes d'autres organisation
terroriste a perpétré un massacre un
massacre et tout le monde ici a vu les
images ignnoble qui nous parviennent
d'Israël dans ce contexte dramatique la
position de la France est très claire
elle a été rappellé à des nombreuses
reprises à tous les niveaux la ministre
l'a rappelé aussi ces trois der der
jours à ses interlocuteurs dans la
région face à l'horreur Israël a le
droit de se défendre et Israël doit le
faire en préservant les population
civiles et dans le cadre du droit
international et des droits humanitaires
qui doivent être pleinement
respectés la situation au Proche Orient
reste le sujet majeur des questions au
gouvernement les manifestations ilienn
qui viennent d'avoir lieu à Paris font
l'objet de beaucoup de questions les
échanges sont
virulents la semaine dernière dans notre
pays des manifestations se sont
déroulées jeudi dernier en particulier
sous les sinistres cris de allahakbar
sinistre cris à quelques mètres du
Bataclan quelques heures après quelques
jours après le décès l'assassinat de
Monsieur Dominique Bernard les Français
sont inquiets les Français sont choqués
avec les députés du rassemblement
national avec Marine Le Pen nous sommes
la voix de ces Français choqués inquiets
et exigeants vous avez pendant des
années criminalisé ceux qui ont lancé
l'alerte vous avez pendant des années
voté des subventions à des associations
complices pourtant il en a fallu du
courage pour nous pour des militants
pour des intellectuels pour dénoncer
cette menace islamiste dans notre pays
allez-vous vous donner nous donner les
moyens juridiques et législatifs de
combattre cette idéologie de lutter
contre ces expressions politiques
intellectuelles culturelles
vestimentaires et son apologie à travers
les manifestations les écrits les
prêches ou bien allez-vous continuer à
interdire des manifestations qui se
déroulent quand
même
merci monsieur le député Chenu vous
aurez constaté que le gouvernement de la
République a été extrêmement clair et
nous avons été les seuls en Europe à le
faire nous avons interdit toutes les
manifestations program qui se sont tenus
dans les heures et dans les jours qui
ont venus en effet nous avons constaté
que la justice administrative alors à
moins que vous remettiez totalement en
cause votre état de droit la justice
administrative a autorisé puisqu'elle a
réformé la décision du préfet de police
la manifestation qui s'est déroulée
dimanche dernier cette manifestation qui
s'estéroulé dimanche dernier pour lequel
nous respectons les décisions de justice
effectivement pour la plupart des
manifestants se sont déroulés dans les
premiers temps de façon tout à fait
convenable et puis sur des slogans
antisémites antisionistes inacceptables
ignomigneux qui n'ont pas été condamnés
malheureusement par les partis
politiques qui ont organisé cette
manifestation monsieur le député il y a
eu plus d'une vingtaine
d'interpellations des personnes qui pour
les services de Monsieur Gard dau
répondront au slogan sur les bébés
décapités qui n'existent pas ou
malheureusement des arguments
antisémistes absolument inaccepbles
la consigne donnée à tous les préfets de
la République c'est d'interdire les
manifestations qui se dérouleront dans
l'ordre public qui peuvent effectivement
poser des questions oui pour soutenir la
cause palestinienne ou les civils
palestiniens mais lorsqu'on sait que des
collectifs comme Palestine vaincra donc
j'espère que le Conseil d'État donnera
raison au ministère de l'Intérieur pour
la dissolution les organise ce sera non
et nous porterons nous au ministère de
l'Intérieur à la justice tous les faits
qui sont contraires au droit merci
Monsieur le Ministre Mons
monsieur le ministre force de constater
que votre loi sur le séparatisme que
vous nous aviez vendu n'a strictement
rien changé alors il faut une
législation particulière nous la
réclamons avec Marine Le Pen qui nomme
qui combat qui empêche l'expression et
même la la visibilité de cette idéologie
islamiste aujourd'hui vous ne nous la
présentez pas vous refusez de combattre
avec une législation particulière la
menace islamiste n'attendez pas qu'il
soit trop
tard dans le contexte de la menace
terroriste la sécurité des
établissements scolaires et celle des
enseignants préoccupent les députés
Gabriel Atal ministre de l'éducation
nationale annonce une enquête flash pour
évaluer le niveau de sécurité des
établissements
scolaires chaque jour des professeurs
craignent d'aller enseigner chaque jour
des élèves angoissent en silence sur le
chemin de l'école chaque jour des
parents s'inquiète le climat dans lequel
est plongée notre école n'est plus
acceptable la peur doit changer de camp
nous avons vu les premières réponses
face à l'urgence avec le déclenchement
du plan attentat mais ce besoin de
sécurité est plus profond et exige une
réponse durable notre école doit revenir
doit redevenir un lieu de paix et de
sérénité nos enseignants nos élèves les
familles ont besoin d'être rassurés sur
leur sécurité quand ils se rendent à
l'école j'ai déclenché une enquête flash
sur tous les établissements scolaire
pour mesurer le niveau actuel de
sécurité les résultats consolidés me
seront transmis dans les prochaines
heures nous nous reverrons dans les
prochains jours avec l'ensemble des
associations d'élus pour s'accorder sur
les mesures essentielles pour continuer
à aller plus loin dans le renforcement
de la sécurité je le dis la règle est
claire on ne doit pas pouvoir pénétrer
dans un établissement scolaire quand on
a rien à y faire et si jamais c'est le
cas où qu'il y a une tentative il faut
que les personnels soient formés pour y
réagir et que les forces de sécurité
reçoivent l'alerte immédiatement pour
intervenir à partir de là charge à
chaque collectivité avec le soutien de
l'État de garantir que nous y parvenons
depuis 2017 nous avons consacré 100
millions d'euros de l'État pour
accompagner les collectivités et nous
continuerons un échange vif marque la
séance du 24 octobre le député LFI de
Paris Emeric Caron accuse le
gouvernement de faire un deux poids de
mesures entre Israéliens et Palestiniens
il suscite des Hué dans
l'hémicycle le 7 octobre dernier le
Hamas s'est rendu coupable de crimes
ignobl contre des civils israéliens plus
de 1400 personnes ont des enfants ont
été tués dans des circonstances qui
suscitent l'effroid l'indignation le
dégoût au CRIM de guerre du Hamas
répondent aujourd'hui les crimes de
guerre de l'armée
israélienne selon les sources
palestiniennes les bombardements sur
Gaza ont déjà fait près de 6000 morts en
grande majorité des civils parmi
lesquels 2400 enfants pourtant on a
l'impression d'un deux poids de mesures
dans l'indignation dans cette assemblée
des voies manquent encore pour dénoncer
le sort subi en ce moment
comme une vie
palestinenneit Moune vie
israélienne aujourd'hui la France
demander la Paro aujourd'hui la France
demander
unit également dénoncer la colonisation
et demander son arrêt c'est le seul
moyen de continuer à croire en la
solution à de états madame la Première
ministre il
nousre
minist dit hier que c'est le chemin que
la France commençait enfin à choisir
mais tout à l'heure depuis Israël le
président de la République n'a pas
prononcé ses mots il a en revanche
proposer que la coalition contre l'État
islamique puisse lutter aussi contre le
Hamas quelles sont les implications
concrètes de ces déclarations pour la
France est-ce que ça veut dire madame la
Première ministre que la France renonce
à exiger un cesser le feu est-ce que ça
veut dire que vous renoncer à exiger le
respect des droits des Palestiniens
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député Caron
depuis 17 jours la France insoumise
montre son vrai visage celui de
l'indignité celui de l'indignité de
pouvoir nommer ce qu'est véritablement
le Hamas c'est-à-dire un mouvement
terroriste aucune cause monsieur le
député Caron aucune cause ne justifie
que l'on assassine que l'on décapite que
l'on brûle des hommes des femmes des
enfants et des bébés c'est ça la réalité
ce que le président Loula ce que le
conseil de sécurité au Brésil nomme le
Hamas en tant que mouvement terroriste
vous n'êtes pas capable de le faire vous
ici la position de la France Monsieur le
député est très claire elle a été
rappelée par le Président de la
République elle a été rappelée par la
première ministre il a été rappelé par
le par la ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères qui est aujourd'hui
encore au Conseil de sécurité à l'ONU
nous demandons aujourd'hui une trêve
humanitaire qui permette d'acheminer
l'aide humanitaire que la France finance
également à hauteur de 20 millions
d'euros pour les Palestiniens nous avons
appelé nous avons appelé à ce que cette
trêve humanitaire puisse amener à un
cesser le feu nous n'avons jamais fait
l'assimilation entre le Hamas et le
peuple palestinien et le président de la
République se rend en ce moment à ramala
nous défendons la solution à deux États
qui est la seule solution qui permette à
deux peuples de vivre côte à côte
en pai la position de la France elle est
claire contrairement à la
vôtre la guerre au Proche Orient et son
impact en France continue d'enflammer
les débats à l'Assemblée nationale des
familles d'otage retenu par le Hamas
sont présents en séance
publique je vais en profiter pour saluer
la présence dans l'hémicycle de familles
et pour leur dire que que nous sommes à
leur côté depuis l'attaque terroriste du
7 octobre dernier nous déplorons la mort
de 35 de nos compatriotes cela fait
aujourd'hui 25 jours que neuf Français
sont détenus en
otage leurs familles sont donc présentes
et je vous
remercie au nom de la représentation
nationale de leur dire collectivement
que nous sommes à leur
côté
[Applaudissements]
dans la majorité on s'inquiète de la
montée de l'antisémitisme tandis qu'à
gauche beaucoup de questions sur la
situation à Gaza où le nombre de morts
notamment d'enfants ne cesse de
grandir depuis le 7 octobre ce sont 840
actes antisémites qui ont été recensés
dans notre pays 430 personnes
interpellées 840 actes antisémites en 3
semaines soit beaucoup beaucoup plus que
durant l'annéecou c'est une véritable
flambée de l'antissémitisme à laquelle
nous assistons dans notre pays insulte
injure menace de mort tag dégradation de
bâtiments agression physique tentative
d'incendie contre des portes
d'appartements cyber harcèlement rythme
le quotidien de beaucoup trop de NS
compatriotes de confessions juives qui
se sentent menacés et qui ont peur cet
antisémitisme grandissant désinhibé dans
la France d'aujourd'hui il fait peur il
nous fait peur il nous fait honte le
combat battre doit être l'affaire de
tous de tous les républicains pas
seulement l'affaire de nos compatriotes
Juifs c'est notre affaire à nous tous
car cet antisémitisme ce n'est pas la
France c'est la négation de la
République française c'est une attaque
contre notre République et nos valeurs
monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous dire à
la représentation nationale à tous les
Français quelles sont les mesures
précises que vous avez misise en place
pour protéger les Français juifs tous
les Juifs en France protéger leur
sécurité et nous dire également quelles
sont les mesures envisagées pour
renforcer la mobilisation notre
mobilisation à tous contre ce poison de
l'antisémitisme merci beaucoup ma cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur Gérald
daranin ministre de l'Intérieur et des
outr mes merci madame la présidente
madame la députée constance grip comme
l'a dit Madame la premierre ministre
président de la République nous a
demandé dès évidemment les drames
ignobles des attentats terroristes
islamistes contre les populations
israéliennes dès le 7 octobre de
renforcer considérablement la sécurité
de tous les lieux où les Français de
confession juives vont pour leur culte
vont évidemment mettre leurs enfants à
l'école s'ils le souhaitent ou dans les
lieux culturel ou communautaire qui
fréquente assidument c'est donc 950
sites partout en France sur le
territoire national que nous protégeons
grâce aux 10000 policiers gendarmes et
militaires de sentinelle qui permettent
en effet de lutter contre cette peur qui
touche légitimement nos compatriotes de
confession juives et dont la République
est là pour les protéger absolument
complètement et jour et nuit ces actes
antisémites ces actes antisémites madame
la député malheureusement ne sont pas
une légende 857 actes antisémites depuis
le 7 octobre c'est-à-dire autant d'actes
antisémit que depuis toute l'année
écoulée en 3 semaines grâce à la
position des des policiers des gendarmes
des milit de sentinelle présent devant
les lieux communautaires que j'ai évoqué
c'est 425 interpellés et je veux dire
ici la fermeté notamment du ministère de
l'Intérieur pour le retrait de titrre
systématique des étrangers qui seraient
parmi ces personnes interpellées et
l'éloignement systématique il y a 27
personnes dans centre de rétention
administratif depuis une semaine du fait
notamment des interpellations fait par
le ministère de de l'intérieur nous
avons également une haine sur sur
Internet 5916 signalements Faros dont de
6 personnes ont été identifiées par les
services du ministère de la Justice et
je vrais donner deux exemples ici pour
qu'prenne qu'il n'y ait pas d'impunité
un individu étranger a été renvoyé dans
son pays le 9 octobre dernier suite à
des crrit de mort aux Juifs mort à
Israël un individu le 28 octobre sur
TikTok qui a appelé à la haine et à la
menace de mort contre le Rabin de
Levallois a non seulement été interpellé
mis en garde à vue et déféré par les
service du ministère de la Justice en
prison merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
des Affaires étrangères Catherine Colona
madame la ministre la France en tant que
étattiers au conflit
israélo-palestinien doit avoir une
position claire elle doit renouer avec
son rôle historique consistant à
défendre le droit international tout le
droit international rien que le droit
international celui-ci
exige la libération sans condition de de
tous les otages civils la protection de
toutes les personnes civiles la mise en
place en urgence d'un corridor
humanitaire permettant d'acheminer les
produits de première nécessité dont les
médicaments pouvez-vous madame la
ministre affirmer aujourd'hui devant
l'Assemblée nationale que la France
appelle à l'instar d'Antonio gouterrez à
un cesser le feu
humanitaire madame la députée andrine
Rousseau vous avez dit que la France
doit agir en responsabilité et vous avez
raison c'est précisément ce que fait
notre
diplomatie c'est d'abord en
responsabilité que la France agit au
plan politique la France a voté en
faveur du texte jordanien présenté à
l'Assemblée générale des Nations unies
texte qui appelait à la mise en place
d'une trêve humanitaire menant à
l'association des hostilités c'est la
position de la France depuis les
premiers jours de ce conflit c'est aussi
la position commune des EUR
exprimé la semaine
dernière c'est en responsabilité
également que nous cherchons avec nos
partenaire dans la région et au-delà un
chemin qui évite un embrasement régional
et permette de tracer une perspective de
paix c'est en fait en responsabilité que
nous rappelons des principes simples la
condamnation du terrorisme du àass et
des crimes abjects qu' a commis le droit
d'Israël à la sécurité et son devoir
d'agir dans le cadre du droit
international et enfin évidemment
l'impérieuse nécessité d'un horizon
politique pour que les Palestiniens et
les Israéliens puissent vivre dans deux
états côte à côte et en paix je vous
remercie mardi 7 novembre la séance
publique est marquée par un échange au
vitriol entre le député RN de la Somme
Jean-Philippe Tangi et le ministre et
porte-parole Olivier verrand
extrait contre ma volonté j'ai été le
témoin de la plus effroyable défaite de
la raison et du plus sauvage triomphe de
la brutalité jamais une génération n'est
tombée d'une telle élévation spirituelle
dans une telle décadence morale quand il
écrit ces mots Stéphan Zwag a fui la
barbarie nazie et un continent submergé
par la haine antisémite que les
démocraties n'avaient pas su étouffer à
temps l'IDRE odieuse de la haine des
Juifs ne vient pas s'écraser contre un
mur unanime de bouclier de GLV de nos
démocraties pour la battre mais ce fr un
chemin à travers l' différence la
lâcheté et le clientélisme l'adre
antisémite s'abreuve encore dans le
canivau des extrémismes mais sa source
essentielle sa source cardinale est
désormais l'islamisme l'islamisme aux
souterraines que les nations on laissé
s'infiltré jaillit à nos visages et peut
nous submerger faute de réaction à la
hauteur de la catastrophe dans nos rues
nos écoles au sein des médias du sport
de la culture et même des plus grandes
universités la haine des Juifs et
partout de la insulte jusqu'au meurtre
qu'avons-nous fait du devoir de mémoire
avons-nous oublié que la barbarie
triomphe des illusions de gens de bien
qui pense vaincre par la simple raison
je dis nous je dis nous car dans un tel
moment aucune division n'est tolérable
Marc bloc affirmé ne revendiquer son
origine que face à un antisémite il est
temps que la France la République
revendique sa civilisation ses valeurs
et son destin contre les antisémites
alors qu'un imam àer n'a reçu qu'une
p mon cher
cèue je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier verrant porte-parole du
gouvernement et ministre en charge du
renouveau démocratique merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député
Tangui l'antisémitisme qui s'exprime sur
les frontons de nos maisons sur les
portes des immeubles dans les injures
qui peuvent être lancées dans les MRO
cet antisémitisme qui fait qu'une partie
de nos concitoyens n'os plus faire ses
courses normalement n'os plus mettre ses
enfants dans les écoles normalement n'os
plus aller au travail normalement n'os
plus prendre des transports en commun
normalement cet antisémitisme est un
fléo que nous condamnons tous et que
nous devons combattre avec acharnement
il est
autant
estant temporael qu'un
anachronisme cet antisémitisme il n'est
pas né au lendemain du 7 octobre il y
avait un antisémitisme pernicieux
insidieux parfois révélé à travers des
actes antisémites je rappelle que la
France déplorait déjà plusieurs
centaines d'actes de cette nature chaque
année cet antisémitisme il croit
désormais dans l'esprit de certain qu'il
serait légitime à exploser au grand jour
comme légitimé par un conflit
israélo-palestinien qui permettrait
enfin à ceux qui ont toujours haïi les
Juifs en secret de pouvoir le faire
cette fois-ci à raison et dans la sphère
publique monsieur le député nous
combattons cet antisémitisme tous ici
dans cette hémicycle monsieur le député
je ne peux je ne peux imaginer qu'un
député de la nation je ne peux imaginer
qu'un député de la nation ne puisse ne
puisse combattre l'antisémitisme mais il
n'y a pas monsieur le député et je le
dirai ici sans polémique il n'y a pas
vous pointez l'extrême gauche je vais
vous pointer vous vous êtes le parti de
la flamme il n'y a pas un bon et anti un
bon et un mauvais antisémitisme il n
sémitisme et quand le président de votre
parti politique il y a 2 jours refuse de
reconnaître que le président fondateur
de votre parti le Front national a été
condamné par la justice française pour
antisémitisme vous ne servez pas la côte
que vous prétendez servir alors soyons
tous uni une fois pour toute contre
l'antisémitisme sans réserve dans tous
les bords de l'hémicycle c'est ainsi la
grandeur de la France Merci monsieur le
ministre voilà pour ce florilège des
questions au Gouvernement largement
dominé par la situation au Proche Orient
c'est la fin de ce numéro des grands
débats on se retrouve très vite sur LCP
ciao